♪ ♪
>> John: THE PRESIDENT’S TOP
MILITARY ADVISORS ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THEY KNOW AND DON’T
KNOW ABOUT RUSSIA SO-CALLED
"BOUNTY" ON U.S. FORCES IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT THE USE OF THE
MILITARY.
THEY DEAL WITH CIVILIAN
DISTURBANCES.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL
SHOWS US TODAY’S TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE HOUSE ARMED SERVICE
COMMITTEE.
>> THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE AND
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS WAS
PRESSED ON THE MILITARY’S ROLE
IN RECENT PROTEST IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
INCLUDING CLEARING
LAFAYETTE PARK NEAR THE
WHITE HOUSE JUNE 1ST.
>> IT’S STILL UNCLEAR TO ME WHO
GAVE THE DIRECTION TO CLEAR THE
PARK AT THAT MOMENT IN TIME.
>> YOU SEE, I FIND THAT HARD TO
BELIEVE.
I’M SORRY, BUT IT’S LIKE A
PRETTY BIG DECISION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THERE.
EVERYONE IS THERE AND IT JUST
SORT OF HAPPENED?
>> WHAT HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED AS
PEACEFUL PROTEST, 50 PARK
POLICE, 60 SECRET SERVICE, AND
SIX NATIONAL GUARD SOLDIERS WERE
INJURED.
INCLUDING ONE WHO WAS HIT IN THE
HEAD WITH A BRICK.
BUT ESPER CAUTIONED AGAINST
BRINGING IN ACTIVE DUTY SOLDIER
IS.
>> USING ACTIVE DUTY FORCES IN A
LAW ENFORCEMENT ROLE SHOULD
REMAIN A LAST RESORT.
>> GENERAL MILLEY WEIGHING IN ON
THE ISSUE IS.
>> WE AS A NATION AS A MILITARY
ARE STILL STRUGGLING WITH
RACISM, AND WE HAVE WORK TO DO.
>> ALSO TAKING AIM AT THE
CIVIL WAR CONFEDERATE NAMES ON
MILITARY BASES ISSUE.
>> IT WAS AN ACT OF TREASON AT
THE TIME AGAINST THE UNION AND
THE STARS & STRIPES.
IT WAS AGAINST THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION.
AND THOSE OFFICERS TURNED THEIR
BACK ON THEIR OATH.
>> SOME LAWMAKERS ARE FOCUSED ON
RECENT REPORTING’S IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND OTHERS
ON LEAKED INTELLIGENCE THE
RUSSIANS OFFERED AFGHAN FIGHTERS
A BOUNTY TO KILL U.S. TROOPS.
>> HAVE YOU RECEIVED AN INTEL
BRIEFING THAT INCLUDED THE WORD
"BOUNTY" WITH RESPECT TO
RUSSIANS AND THE KILLING OF
AMERICAN MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM?
>> CONGRESSMAN, TO THE BEST OF
MY RECOLLECTION I HAVE NOT
RECEIVED A BRIEFING THAT
INCLUDED THE WORD "BOUNTY."
>> SAYING THAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE
BEEN MEDDLING IN AFGHANISTAN
SINCE 2013 PRETTY PROMISED THAT
IF IT IS TRUE, RUSSIA HAS A
BOUNTY PROGRAM, THE U.S. WILL